welcome to the civilian playing hmm and
Danielle aus something like that from
Italy and turn pretty good an open
society I'm going from the count on
variation um okay maybe a quick be five
I don't think I did much much um lines
like that on video maybe t 697 first
accelerating the play on the queenside I
don't want to get into Knight f6 and d5
yeah one thing that's possible is some
95 I must be cautious about that as well
okay nice playing very quickly now and
this kind of sacrifices on a really a
playable quite often so I'm not
particularly surprised that it is played
here yeah so if I take it he takes d5
yeah he's he obviously has compensation
that's clear the evo hmm ok yeah the
question is one question is is before
really hanging hmm I can play five just
okay let's do that
just ignore that for the time being the
the capture is always very tricky with
night f5 coming in 96 coming I really
don't want that if I was very weakening
but okay before was probably really
hanging so what's my next move Jeb
Knight f6 you can just take a play five
not easy not easy to develop here yeah
ok so is going for the d6 poor maybe I
can play night c5 maybe yeah that that
covers d6 and term maybe prepares not f6
so that after the capture and ivory and
I need to take with a poner what I was
trying to say is that I'm covering the
b7 bishop Wow why don't understand this
move to be honest not at least not at
first okay if I take on d5 ed6 is
obviously very dangerous but I can take
here what's the big big point now so
that's so terrible for me this position
might have six takes hmm
I'll just take with the pond it's nuts
bad I guess Knight f6 spawn f6 I don't
turn I don't see the the big issue at
the moment I maybe you can take here on
c5 90 of six GF Queen d8 rook t8 Roxy 5
Bishop c5 Pacific p7 check I've got this
check on the one mmm not sure okay let's
see what is going to do it's not clear
that he will take on f6 of course there
are other other possibilities like that
aunt is obviously very much inclined on
playing this kind of cool moves ok so I
cannot really take an take here now
maybe maybe keep it simple Bishop g5
Bishop e7
yeah just Bishop e7 I should be okay I
can take on f6 maybe this is my eyes ok
thought this is maybe why I was thinking
so long ok here I'm just attacking d5
now and I'm completing development now I
really don't think that this is so
terrible my piece coordination is quite
decent what I can just take this why not
you
check okay so chill that's just a piece
okay so what's the easiest way maybe
he'd take here 97 so a double attack on
jun 5 and the rook I know I've worked
the 96 and the rook is so completely
trapped test yeah I can take that that's
no square wait I'm sorry yeah this was
certainly dangerous for me no doubt
about it but I'm not not sure how bad it
was yeah probably this is this is really
tricky here there's also just night a 2
quite quite a possibility intending to
just open up the position here this kind
of this kind of setup it's also quite
promising i would say and without any
sacrifice okay 95 is possible though no
no question yeah a tab Jim can I take
the problem is I need to put something
on his have let's say here and this is
really tricky now let's say nitey
m-maybe I can take and play 95 okay even
that is not not really clear yeah or
something like that there's this
immediate immediate term attacking moves
now that's very very dangerous so I
think this is relatively speaking better
you know 95 and aha so here the computer
gives an improvement with Bishop f4
interesting
yeah oh this is obviously very shaky but
how bad is it and I go in 5m I am am I
am getting getting smashed quickly am
Not sure ice cut this in vaults on yeah
that's very very problematic of like
probably very bad yeah this i'm not sure
i don't think it's it's so convincing
know the computer is going down to
giving this as equal yeah yeah this just
I just took it to you keep it simple I
was I was thinking about this check I
know this smooth but this is not working
at all the ideas obviously to to to do
that but what I forgot about I kept is
chicky Jang forcing the bishop back and
he of course black is totally winning so
this and now this was played yeah and
here he just just blundered this in one
move yeah white it probably should just
play a normal move maybe him something
like that and then i have ninety-seven
well this is this is the problem okay
night a seven is a move that the
computer recommends
you know computers stock to ship some
some are asking what engine it is is
always stock for Shia in my analysis
because I tried to to get the houdini to
work here but for some reason this is
always crashing the the software so I'm
staking taking a stock fish which is
okay yeah here just it's just the
blunder what can you do yeah very very
tricky position probably the the way I
played this it's not not exactly great
ignoring them yeah after g3 ignoring the
development okay thanks for watching